[Música]
recientemente el alcalde de la ciudad de
Nueva York Erick Adams declaró el estado
de emergencia debido a la gran cantidad
de migrantes que llegan diariamente y
que han desatado una crisis humanitaria
en esa ciudad la mayoría de ellos son
enviados desde los estados de Florida
Texas y Arizona que coinciden en ser
estados que están siendo gobernados por
republicanos en promedio la ciudad de
Nueva York recibe entre 5 y 6 autobuses
diarios llenos de migrantes las
autoridades de la ciudad tienen una
previsión de hasta 100.000 personas van
a llegar a esta ciudad en los próximos
meses para ello han habilitado entonces
42 hoteles a modo de refugios y han
distribuido acerca de 5.500 menores de
edad en diferentes escuelas públicas de
los diferentes condados sin embargo las
autoridades de Nueva York han reclamado
un poco más de apoyo por parte de las
autoridades del Estado homónimo del
estado de Nueva York
y también de las autoridades federales
la alcaldía estima destinar más de mil
millones de dólares en respuesta a este
aumento en el flujo migratorio hacia
esta ciudad de la costa este de Estados
Unidos la situación entonces comienza a
hacer crítica sobre todo por las
condiciones en las que están los
migrantes con un invierno que está Ya a
punto de comenzar está la vuelta de la
esquina muchos no tienen la ropa
adecuada para hacer frente a estas bajas
temperaturas están agotados después de
una travesía de meses a lo largo de
Centroamérica y México hasta llegar a
Estados Unidos es tan débiles y con
muchas necesidades así están las cosas
veamos más detalles en el siguiente
informe que fue preparado por la
redacción de France 24
estado de emergencia en Nueva York
decretó el alcalde Erick Adams a través
de una orden ejecutiva tras la llegada
masiva de migrantes desde la frontera
sur del país
esta orden ejecutiva ordenará
formalmente a todos los organismos
pertinentes que coordinen sus esfuerzos
para construir los centros de ayuda
humanitaria a la vez que suspenderá
ciertos requisitos de uso del suelo para
acelerar este proceso
la ciudad gastará mil millones de
dólares para gestionar la afluencia de
solicitantes de asilo desde principios
de septiembre han llegado entre 5 y 6
autobuses diarios a la ciudad pero este
jueves llegaron nueve unas 17.000
personas arribaron a Nueva York desde
abril para Adams esta gran afluencia de
migrantes ahonda una crisis ya existente
una ciudad que se recupera de una
pandemia mundial en cursos se ve
desbordada por la crisis humanitaria
hecha por manos humanas hemos recibido
parte de la ayuda que hemos solicitado
la hemos recibido pero necesitamos más
estamos al borde del precipicio
Texas enviado buses llenos de migrantes
hacia Washington Nueva York y Chicago
aún así el gobernador republicano de
Texas dice que seguirá haciéndolo
continuaremos transportando a los
migrantes a Nueva York DC Chicago para
aliviar a nuestras ciudades fronterizas
hasta que bailen haga su trabajo para
asegurar la frontera el gobernador de
Florida el republicano ron de santis
llevó recientemente en avión a un grupo
de unos 50 migrantes a la isla de Marta
swinger en Massachusetts los demócratas
acusan a abbott y a desantes de utilizar
a los migrantes como un arma política
es una decisión política la de los
gobernadores de estos tres estados esta
decisión de enviar migrantes a otros
rincones del país Qué hay de los
derechos y de las garantías que tienen
los migrantes en Estados Unidos muchos
de ellos reclaman que han sido enviados
bajo engaños incluso han demandado al
gobernador de Florida ronda santis qué
respuesta está dando el Gobierno Federal
liderado por el presidente Joe biden
porque una guerra política entre estos
dos partidos el republicano y el
demócrata deja en el medio a personas
con grandes necesidades y con el deseo
de reiniciar sus vidas en Estados Unidos
pues lo vamos a analizar en unos minutos
para conversar sobre este tema hemos
invitado a Luis Dávila él es analista
político e integrante del comité
nacional demócrata también está con
nosotros jaypica arroll él es estratega
republicano y analista para seguridad
nacional y gobernanza inclusiva en el
centro Joseph rini en y para políticas
públicas también Recuerden que ustedes
otros televidentes también hacen parte
de esta conversación de este debate
pueden dejar sus comentarios y sus
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
estamos en Twitter en Facebook también
en instagram no se encuentran como
arroba el debate f24 o arroba el
debate_f24 Santiago que es mi cuenta
personal en la etiqueta es numeral el
debate f24 no olviden también que los
contenidos de este programa también
están disponibles en diferentes
plataformas de podcast no se encuentran
en Apple podcast en Spotify deezer y
TuneIn
pues comienzo entonces dándole la
bienvenida a Luis Luis Gracias por
acompañarnos hoy en el programa y bueno
Punto de partida que es la primera
pregunta que lanzo para conocer
opiniones de los de los invitados pero
es una disputa entre partidos que está
causando una crisis humanitaria en
Estados Unidos O está comenzando Esta
crisis humanitaria por lo menos en el
estado de Nueva York Cuál es el análisis
que usted hace
Yo creo que es una una crisis que
ciertamente lleva lleva mucho tiempo no
la crisis migratoria en los Estados
Unidos es un problema verdad ya
muchísimos años no obstante
esta nueva táctica digamos política de
sacar provecho de utilizar
almas personas humanas como como dirían
en Puerto Rico como Carne de cañón para
propósitos políticos me parece que es
algo nuevo que estamos viendo y que
ciertamente está causando mucha noticia
no es no es de extrañar que estamos a
escasamente menos de un mes para unas
elecciones de medio término que
definirán verdad quién Qué partido va a
controlar el congreso verdad o el senado
de los Estados Unidos O sea que no es no
está extrañar que esta estrategia que
han tomado los republicanos
particularmente en estados del Sur
comienza verdad a estallar en una
emergencia fíjense que fíjense que esto
comienza en abril porque ya sabían el
efecto que iba a tener ya para
septiembre octubre en un período
Así que parece que ahí es donde
ahora le doy la palabra a JP también
allí en Estados Unidos para conocer su
opinión para este Punto de partida a
usted le parece que esto es una disputa
entre los diferentes partidos entre los
demócratas y los republicanos Y esta
disputa está llevando a una crisis
humanitaria Cuál es su opinión
Mira estoy estoy de acuerdo que eso es
una situación realmente
desafortunada triste y que o sea ambos
lados han hecho cosas que simplemente no
van a resolver esto no van a mejorar
esto en que como el reportaje que mostró
previamente de que estos gobernadores
están mandando a personas a
ciudades y estados
donde las políticas gobernantes son
diferentes de las de los estados donde
llegaron estos migrantes
Mira eso no no es una solución
y creo que en realidad la meta de eso
que han hecho estos gobernadores
es precisamente esto en que quieren que
los dos medios que la prensa presten
atención a este tema de inmigración lo
cual ha sido realmente una una crisis no
solo ahorita pero realmente por y es un
tema el cual tiene que ser tratado con
de manera delicada con compasión y
desafortunadamente
No creo que esto ha sido el caso con lo
que han elegido hacer estos gobernadores
pero tampoco es compasión que el
Gobierno Federal no trate esto Con
urgencia entonces en fin realmente
a nivel Estatal como a nivel Federal
a los dos se han equivocado y creo que
el pueblo estadounidense realmente
necesita una solución más que todo lo
que necesita esta solución son los
migrantes los cuales están arriesgando
sus vidas para mejorar sus vidas y eso
es un tema complicado el cual requiere
que las personas piensen en sí mismos no
como demócratas no como republicanos
pero como personas preocupadas por el
bienestar de otros seres humanos
continuó con usted para hacer la ronda
la inversa Luis mencionaba que esto pues
funciona como una estrategia porque
estamos a poco menos de un mes de las
elecciones de medio término y hay mucha
presión para los partidos en Estados
Unidos incluso para el gobierno de turno
del presidente biden esta estrategia
Entonces desde la republicano que busca
con este tipo de acciones poner sobre la
mesa una discusión Nacional sobre el
tema migratorio dejar en evidencia que
el Gobierno Federal no ha actuado o
simplemente marcar un precedente sobre
la posición que tiene el partido
republicano frente a los temas
migratorios no quieren migrantes en los
Estados republicanos Cuál es su análisis
creo que desafortunadamente o sea es dos
cosas en que uno o sea estos estados los
cuales han estado mandando migrantes a
otros estados es verdad decir que
particularmente en sus comunidades en la
frontera en ciudades y pueblos en la
frontera entre los Estados Unidos y
México realmente o sea están al límite
de sus capacidades de o sea recursos y
habilidades de ayudar y asistir a
personas las cuales están cruzando la
frontera Entonces eso sí es verdad Pero
lo que han hecho no es la solución
lo único que va a cumplir son dos cosas
uno como usted ha dicho
va a resultar en que este tema se hable
de a nivel nacional justo como ha dicho
antes estas elecciones unas semanas de
medio término y también la otra cosa que
logra es que en elecciones medio término
muchas veces
realmente se trata de la manera en la
cual se hace la campaña creo por ambos
partidos republicanos y demócratas más
que todo es para que sus propios
votantes votantes que ya se identifican
con un partido o el otro vayan a votar
en vez de tratar de alcanzar a votantes
independientes ocentristas en fin el
resultado es tomar acciones de o sea de
de teatro político feo el cual pone en
peligro de las vidas de personas
verdaderas de personas que realmente
Necesitan ayuda claro y por último diría
que precisamente por eso en que no es
una elección en la cual creo que la meta
es alcanzar los votantes centristas pero
si no motivar a votantes de su propio
partido a votar en el caso del partido
republicano creo que esto es una manera
desafortunada desafortunadamente muy fea
de tratar de mandar una señal digamos a
votantes que estuvieron a favor de las
políticas de inmigración del ex
presidente Trump a decir que ellos
también están a favor de los tipos de
resurrecciones las cuales él tuvo
durante su presidencia y la manera en la
cual están tratando de mostrar esto es
muy fea y muy triste importante ese
punto es aclaración Que hace usted JP
sobre este foco en los votantes estarían
apostando justamente a sus grandes bases
de votantes republicanos más allá que
cautivar a otros votantes del centro
paso a darle la palabra entonces a Luis
en la isla de Puerto Rico para hacerle
la misma pregunta sobre esta estrategia
a nivel
político pero desde el otro lado de la
moneda pensaría uno que para los
demócratas pues es la coyuntura perfecta
para poder hacer acciones que den buenos
resultados que vuelvan a darle la
posibilidad al gobierno de Mostrar
resultados en el tema migratorio creo
que es una factura que le va cobrando al
presidente biden día a día pensaría uno
que es el momento de actuar y de dar
resultados pero el debate vuelve y queda
sobre la mesa y es muy criticada la Casa
Blanca en este momento por las acciones
que está tomando para hacer frente a
esta situación ya veíamos al gobernador
Perdón al alcalde de la ciudad de Nueva
York pidiendo más ayuda Federal o sea lo
que están haciendo no es suficiente
aquel le están apostando entonces
Bueno lo que ocurre Es que para
verdaderamente atender el tema se tiene
que atender en el congreso requiere
legislación y como bien sabes pues la
composición del Congreso de los estados
de los Estados Unidos particularmente
del senado requiere de 60 votos para
poder pasar legislación a probar
legislación lo quiere decir que la
composición actual de ese de ese senado
requeriría que 10 republicanos unieran y
estoy y llegan a un acuerdo bipartita
para atender el tema migratorio Y eso no
ha ocurrido Así es que es poco lo que
verdaderamente puede hacer el Gobierno
Federal yo creo que la la declaración de
una emergencia por parte del alcalde es
una es una muy que tiene mucho mérito y
es muy estratégica también porque uno es
verdad y los que no conocen de de Cómo
opera el Gobierno Federal es cuando se
dé cuando inicialmente se declara un
desastre o una emergencia una
declaración de emergencia de desastre
eso activa automáticamente los
protocolos de FEMA Verdad que es la
agencia Federal para el manejo de
emergencias verdad
En ese sentido el el declarar la
emergencia Entonces ahora permite que
efema pueda intervenir y que a través de
FEMA se pueda financiar parte de lo que
va a ser la respuesta a los miles de
inmigrantes que están llegando a Nueva
York por ejemplo usted mencionaba al
principio de su programa que 42 hoteles
se están utilizando actualmente como
vivienda o refugio para estos
inmigrantes y muy probablemente se
estaría utilizando el el el famoso
programa de tsi que es un temperature
assistance program verdad O mejor dicho
traducido al español Un refugio
temporero un programa de vivienda
temporal que es lo que se está dando
aquí Yo creo que con las declaraciones
de emergencias le permite una
oportunidad al Gobierno Federal para a
través de femas poder proveer más ayudas
a estas ciudades
Así que un punto importante también es
que el alcalde Nueva York fue muy claro
en decir que esto es una ciudad que
apenas se está recuperando del covid
recordaremos verdad hace apenas dos años
estábamos viendo todavía imágenes de una
ciudad completamente desierta pérdida
multimillonarias a través de toda la
ciudad una una emigración masiva fuera
de la ciudad verdad a otras
jurisdicciones que también tiene un
costo en términos de los recaudos que
pueda ser el gobierno y el estado de
Nueva York encima de eso le tiras ahora
a este problema en medio de lo que viene
siendo verdad con el cambio climático
moviéndose al invierno Personas que
quizás no también en verdad
probablemente no tienen la indumentaria
que se necesita para poder sobrevivir en
ese frío por Tantos meses es un problema
muy muy serio y que y que claramente
requiere de esa declaración de
emergencia claro la declaración de
emergencia lo que uno puede deducir es
que hay una presión sobre el sistema
local el sistema de ayuda que puede dar
la ciudad de Nueva York pero continuó
con usted Luis para preguntarle qué tan
presionado está entonces el sistema
Federal porque migrantes siguen llegando
Nueva York ya declara este estado de
emergencia pero la frontera está
completamente saturada de personas
tratando de llegar no es la única ciudad
que está teniendo problemas justamente
Texas dice que uno de sus argumentos
para enviar a estas personas hasta Nueva
York y Massachusetts es que sus puestos
fronterizos y refugios en su territorio
están completamente llenos bajo que
tanta presión está Entonces el gobierno
de biden y el sistema Federal para
atender esto teniendo el panorama que
usted explica sale También Estados
Unidos de la crisis que ha dejado el
covid 19 se enfrenta a esta coyuntura
bueno claramente la presión la tiene
porque es es el partido de gobierno no
pero creo que hay que creo que se están
dirigiendo hacia utilizar los recursos
federales para manejar emergencias para
poder atenderlo tal vez no tanto a corto
plazo pero tal vez más a mediano plazo
en lo que es verdad esto se atiende
directamente por el congreso claramente
las elecciones de medio término van a
definir lo que podría ser un nuevo
liderato en el congreso demócrata o
republicano Se esperan cambios en ambos
partidos de ser de ser victoriosos así
es que yo creo que la presión está ahí y
ciertamente el país le queda todavía dos
años de dos años y medio de
administración y esos dos años clave que
también demostrar que las promesas que
hizo y las a lo que se comprometió en el
2020 es algo que que verdad que que ha
tratado de y que ha tenido logros dentro
de esa dentro de ese tema le doy la
palabra usted para preguntarle Y para
ponernos en contexto a las personas que
estamos fuera de Estados Unidos pensaría
uno que por el componente
de la población de Estados Como por
ejemplo Florida o Texas incluso Arizona
también que es fronterizo pensaría uno
que son estados que son un poco más
abiertos al tema migratorio que estarían
un poco más abiertos a manejar la
situación de una manera
donde no se pongan entre dicho las
garantías de los Derechos Humanos para
estos migrantes donde no se ponga en
entredicho el gasto innecesario de
recursos públicos Cómo es el contexto
político de estos estados para uno
entender que la estén cerrando la puerta
a los migrantes
Mira yo diría que creo que el contexto
político es uno en el cual de los tres
estados que han nombrado para comenzar
especialmente en el caso de Arizona en
Florida aunque políticamente se
consideran
competitivos
creo que la gran mayoría analista
políticos estarían de acuerdo que más y
más son estados
republicanos en temas de cómo cómo votan
las personas sus actitudes sobre ciertos
temas de política pública en fin el
hecho de que esos estados son unos los
cuales se consideran muy competitivos en
un año de elecciones presidencial
no es la misma situación no es la misma
realidad necesariamente de actitudes ni
la manera que se votan para oficiales
dentro de sus estados Incluyendo los
gobernadores los cuales son los que
están utilizando su autoridad para tomar
este tipo de acciones
y encima diría que o sea este tema
es un tema que creo que muchas personas
a pensar que definitivamente sin duda es
algo de de tema de derechos humanos y de
y de dignidad humana creo que hay muchas
personas Cuando lo ven brevemente en las
noticias en lo ven más como un tema
económico y quizás si alguien no tiene
un trabajo o
si están teniendo dificultades
económicas en su propia vida y están
viendo en la televisión que alguien está
haciendo bienvenido quizás creo que
desafortunadamente piensen personas
piensan que estas personas estos
migrantes quizás van a tratar de o sea
tratar de conseguir un trabajo el cual
ellos quieren o sea creo que aún a pesar
de que la economía definitivamente anda
mejor que hace dos años aún en su
momento de transición económica en los
Estados Unidos y con eso viene creo que
bastante miedo y
incertidumbre para muchas personas y
entonces con ese miedo esa incertidumbre
creo que estos gobernadores han tomado
han tomado ventaja de esos sentimientos
en la manera que han decidido tratar
Este es el tema y también diría que la
otra cosa aquí es que
como como dijo Luis que o sea el
Gobierno Federal realmente
desafortunadamente no puede hacer mucho
sin la cooperación del Congreso la cual
yo creo que va a tener ni en las
próximas semanas ni en los próximos
meses y
eso es lo que creo que votantes cuando
miran la falda cuando ven la falta de
acción en Washington hasta si la
comparan con lo que están haciendo su
gobernadores Aunque quizás no están de
acuerdo con los detalles con la manera
que lo hacen por lo menos ven acción y
desafortunadamente
acción negativa está mejor vista Quizás
por algunas personas que falta de acción
total o por lo menos la percepción de
falta de acción total hablemos por
ejemplo de fondos públicos solamente
para dar una cifra para para que
mencionen ustedes lo que está costando
esto por ejemplo a la gobernación de
Texas que es un estado petrolero grande
parte del motor económico de Estados
Unidos ha enviado desde el pasado mes de
abril cerca de 7000 migrantes no
solamente a la ciudad de Nueva York sino
también al Estado de Massachusetts Y eso
le ha costado a las arcas del estado de
Texas cerca de 13 millones de dólares no
sería mejor invertir esta cantidad de
dinero en mejorar los programas en
mejorar la infraestructura en la
frontera en hacer frente a la situación
ellos mismos allí que tirarle el
problema y lanzarle la pelota a otro
estado que ya vemos que está
desbordándose por lo menos la ciudad de
Nueva York luego el problema puede
empezar a crecer a otras localidades o
condados cercanos como lo vio usted
invertir esos 13 millones de dólares en
otro tipo de cosas que pagar aviones y
buses a Nueva York
Mira o sea eso sería o sea algo ideal no
pero eso no es lo que consigue cobertura
eso no es lo que consigue que nosotros
tengamos esta conversación eso no es lo
que consigue Que el Gobierno Federal
Presta atención lo que está pasando en
estos estados O sea que
desafortunadamente
creo que o sea estos gobernadores han
elegido
[Música]
atraer atención a este tema de una
manera realmente desafortunada pero
han cumplido su meta la cual ha sido que
hay una conversación Nacional sobre el
tema y que quizás para los que están o
sea los que quizás quieren ser reelectos
o unas semanas que se les vea que ellos
están tomando acción y en vez de hacer
nada y fin
una cifra que ha dicho usted cuando
personas Piensan en la deuda Nacional de
los Estados Unidos enorme
ese tipo de cifras realmente es enana
Comparado a la deuda nacional lo cual
creo que es lo que muchas personas
Piensan en cuando Piensan en la economía
en qué piensan que hasta algo tan
pequeño como lo que ha dicho usted que
ni siquiera eso el gobierno debe de
estar o sea gastando quizás en
programas dentro de su propio estado y
que si el estado Ya ya no puede asistir
a personas que gente se deshagan de
ellos lo cual es Es triste
Luis le doy la palabra a usted ahora en
la isla de Puerto Rico Ya pues este
grupo de personas ya está en territorio
estadounidense muchos de ellos están
esperando una respuesta por parte de las
autoridades migratorias para resolver
sus sus temas de solicitud de asilo o
reagrupación familiar son diferentes los
casos para estas personas están digamos
de una manera legal dentro del
territorio de Estados Unidos están
esperando respuestas incluso algunos de
ellos pues ya están listos para ponerse
a trabajar y comenzar su vida allí que
dicen las autoridades Entonces cómo van
a ser el proceso de de incorporación a
la sociedad de Estados Unidos va a haber
no sé
mayor agilidad para concederles el
permiso de trabajo va a haber
oportunidades para ingresar a las
escuelas para que los hijos empiecen a
educarse a aprender el idioma cómo va a
ser el proceso entonces de estas
personas que están allí en Nueva York y
en esta isla en el estado de
Massachusetts
eso eso es un tremendo punto que traes
porque la gente piensa que todo el que
pasa por la por la frontera
automáticamente entra y la realidad es
que muchos son deportados verdad muchos
muchos lo sacan del país los que se
están moviendo y que están moviéndose
entre Estados son personas que como
habían dichos ha mencionado están
solicitando asilo o tienen algún tipo de
permiso o alguna disposición en la ley
que le permite permanecer en el país el
problema es Y esto es un problema que
Que antecede obviamente la
administración biden Es que el cúmulo de
casos que existe ahora mismo en términos
de los casos de asilo que se ven los
tribunales es sumamente largo y es un
proceso que toma mucho mucho mucho
tiempo de hecho yo este año yo soy
abogado de profesión y litigamos un caso
en el
clientes estaban solicitando asilo eran
unos clientes del Salvador era un caso
probono y lo ganamos pero fue un caso
que Nosotros llamamos trabajando hacía
cuatro años
que es muchísimo muchísimo tiempo
durante todo ese tiempo esta familia que
les estoy mencionando obviamente no
revelaré su identidad tenían permisos de
trabajo en los Estados Unidos sus hijos
estudiaban en las escuelas públicas de
hecho estando en los Estados Unidos
tuvieron un segundo bebé ese bebé nació
ciudadano americano Así es que
imagínense cuatro años después ya con un
niño ya de casi cuatro años que es
completamente ciudadano está
completamente integrado al sistema
educativo etcétera que una familia
tengan que estar durmiendo todas las
noches pensando será mañana será la
semana que viene me tendré que ir en un
mes denegarán el nacido sino Y eso
solamente un caso que yo le puedo
mencionar Estos son decenas Mira O sea
que yo creo que como parte nuevamente de
la reforma migratoria famosa clichosa
que siempre escuchamos creo que se tiene
que atender el tema de asilo con una con
una forma más expedita yo creo que eso
no debería de ser algo que se vean los
tribunales por ejemplo el caso que yo
tuve que litigar por ejemplo se sentía
como si fuese de verdad hasta un caso
criminal en cierto sentido verdad en
términos de que es un litigio fuerte de
tener que presentar evidencia
objeciones etcétera que no me parece que
poder probar un caso de asilo requiera
tanto andamiaje y tanto recurso de parte
del gobierno en ese sentido así que nada
volviendo a su pregunta inicial ya hemos
visto que 5.500 menores han sido
trasladados o han sido inscritos en
escuelas públicas en Nueva York y ese
número continuará creciendo pero
precisamente por eso es que el alcalde
Adams ha solicitado la ayuda que ha
solicitado eso que luego pronto va a
empezar a ver presión el sistema
educativo también A cuántos niños más va
a poder recibir porque pues el invierno
no ha empezado oficialmente están en
pleno otoño pero siguen llegando a
personas todos los días Entonces es
presión sobre el sistema de salud
presión sobre los organismos que se
encargan de agencias de Caridad también
la educación es decir esto es una
presión general para el sistema no
solamente para para el gobernador o para
el alcalde de la ciudad sino para toda
la comunidad en general paso a
preguntarle ahora a JP por esa demanda
que hay por un grupo de migrantes que
estaba en el estado de la Florida y
dicen haber sido engañados y enviados a
el estado de Massachusetts en un vuelo
que fue pagado por la gobernación del
estado de Florida han impuesto una
demanda contra el gobernador de santis
esto que tanto puede prosperar este caso
se demorará años tal vez en llegar a un
a un veredicto
Sí mira creo que es terrible y pero
precisamente a lo que dice sí creo que
va a demorar años entonces vamos a tener
esa que o sea el cálculo político
desafortunadamente es pensar que bueno
ya cuando sea un tema en ante las Cortes
ya no será relevante para el futuro
político del gobernador el cual se
especula quizás va a presentar una
candidatura para la nominación del
partido republicano para la presidencia
en el 2024 O sea que
otra vez es pensamiento realmente a
corto plazo en vez de largo plazo y sin
realmente priorizar o pensar en que
sería bueno para el bienestar de esta
persona
vulnerables buscando una vida mejor pero
algo que quiero dejar muy claro es que
en los estados de Florida Arizona Texas
precisamente por su por su geografía por
las comunidades que viven ahí que esos
son estado donde yo creo que o sea hay
personas de buena voluntad o sea yo creo
que realmente esos eso es el caso en que
estas acciones por guardadores no
reflejan necesariamente los pensamientos
de
las personas que viven en estos Estados
en que quizás estos votantes están
frustrados pero no creo que ni uno de
ellos realmente
quiere ser cruel y quiero que eso quede
bien claro especialmente considerando
claramente
y
he tenido éxito en lograr sus sueños
demuestran millones de casos a lo largo
de ancho de Estados Unidos no solamente
en Texas Arizona y Florida sino a lo
largo de toda la Unión Americana ya me
quedan pocos minutos para finalizar el
programa paso al bloque final y tengo
unas cifras del mes de agosto las cifras
de septiembre todavía no han salido pero
los agentes migratorios recibieron cerca
de 203 mil personas en la frontera sur
de Estados Unidos y la mayoría de los
migrantes procedían de tres países muy
puntuales Venezuela Nicaragua y Cuba
constituyen alrededor de 56.000 de las
llegadas
que han llegado pues allí hasta frontera
son el 28% del total según estos datos
federales Luis tal vez la estrategia sea
ayudar a estos países a mejorar sus
condiciones o hacer transiciones
democráticas para mejorar las
condiciones de sus ciudadanos y que no
tengan que dejar sus países y dirigirse
a Estados Unidos o esto es un sueño muy
fantasioso el que le planteó en este
panorama
absolutamente sería la solución ideal no
y va un poco a lo que decía
amlo al principio cuando fue cuando
pelea como Poco después de que fue
electo de que él quería mejor mejorar
las condiciones en México para que la
gente no pudiese que es tan siquiera
pensar en irse del país pero pero una
cosa es lo que uno dice y lo que uno
quiere y otra cosa es la realidad
política y jurídica con la que nos
encontramos usted mencionó ahí tres
países Venezuela Nicaragua y Cuba los
tres yo puedo pensar muchísimas cosas
que tienen en común entre los tres y y
fallidas verdad políticas fallidas
verdad Y eso podríamos dedicar otra hora
de programa Claro
pero por supuesto yo lo que creo Es que
también
hay que hay que darle sí obviamente todo
esto es es importante desde un punto de
vista teórico legal pero hay que hay que
ser un poco conscientes de que se trata
de que se trata de familias separadas se
trata de muchos casos de destierros no
de uno
tomar Su patria para para buscar mejores
oportunidades y pienso que nosotros los
que vivimos los Estados Unidos los que
somos ciudadanos americanos tenemos esa
responsabilidad como ciudadanos del
primer mundo de abrir nuestras puertas
de ayudar al prójimo Claro claro Cómo
podemos brindarle las mismas
oportunidades que tienen mis hijos que
nacieron en esta tierra en este país
como se las podemos brindar a alguien
que tal vez no nació aquí y no las tuvo
en su lugar de origen pero que si la
puede tener aquí esa yo creo que debe
ser el norte de todo Jake y su su
opinión sobre este tema para el cierre
tal vez la estrategia sea destinar más
fondos para ayudar a estos países no
solamente a los tres que mencioné sino
también a otros países como Colombia de
los países Centroamericanos para mejorar
condiciones allí
los planes que ha tenido el Gobierno
Federal en cuanto a ese tema tal vez no
están dando resultados
sí es este tema realmente muestra o sea
precisamente que lo que han hecho estos
gobernadores este teatro político en que
realmente este este tema es mucho más
complicado el hecho de que trata también
con temas de política exterior lo cual
es solamente bajo la autoridad del
Gobierno Federal
que sí En el caso de Mira de Venezuela
Cuba Nicaragua estos son los sociedades
las cuales
no son libres o sea sus gobiernos son O
sea la manera en la cual no no respetan
los Derechos Humanos es bien documentada
por múltiples ongs
gobiernos alrededor del mundo Entonces
esto es un tema el cual no solamente se
trata de política doméstica de seguridad
fronteriza Bueno pues les agradezco por
haber hecho este análisis la audiencia
de France 24 el tiempo no es suficiente
para analizar todas las aristas que
tiene el tema migratorio en Estados
Unidos Les agradezco por haber estado
con nosotros es todo por hoy y el nombre
del equipo técnico les agradezco su
sintonía la producción del programa
estuvo a cargo de Luis Fernando Montes y
la producción de invitados a cargo de
Tania Herrera Gracias por estar con
nosotros pero Siguen con Franz 24
[Música]